how did bullet time go from a filmmaking
phrase to a core aspect of the matrix
resurrections how much of a doors fan do
you need to be to understand the new
film these are the lines in matrix
resurrections that mean more than you
realize
early in the film neo's co-worker jude
tells him quote i'm a geek raised by
machines he's ostensibly talking about
how he grew up playing video games but
it's clear that a line this blatant
carries some extra meaning part of this
line is smack in the face obvious he's a
dude who lives in the matrix he was
literally raised by machines what's less
obvious however is how much it
foreshadows jude's true nature when bugs
meets neo she tells him jude is actually
working with the agents sure enough jude
is on the lookout for neo which is more
than a good enough reason for neo to
leave with bugs he wasn't just raised by
machines as a human but as a potential
threat it's also possible that jude's
name means more than it seems much of
the matrix series can be read as a
christ allegory as such it's not a
stretch to assume that jude the name of
a man who betrays neo is derived from
judas
in the first act of resurrections
jonathan graf's smith tells neo that
their company has been commissioned to
make a fourth matrix game before
delivering one of the most meta-textual
lines of the film that's the thing about
stories they never really end
resurrections is a sequel to a long
dormant series both in real life and as
a game in universe so of course the
story never ended the line is true
literally and meta textually given that
resurrections is in large part a matrix
movie about making matrix movies what's
easier to overlook especially if you
haven't seen the sequels in a while is
that it stands in direct opposition to
what we heard in the third movie in
revolutions neo is told by the oracle
that everything that has a beginning has
an end after the oracle is absorbed by
smith the agent himself delivers the
line which clues neo in on the sacrifice
he needs to make to save both the
machine world and the human world of
zion
multiple characters throughout
resurrections use the phrase bullet time
some of the game developers use it to
describe the old matrix games the
analyst uses it to describe technology
and techniques he innovated to get the
upper hand over neo most fans will
recognize bullet time as the terminology
long used to describe the franchise's
slo-mo fight scenes
you move like they do
i've never seen anyone move that fast so
this just seems like an inside joke
right well it isn't not that but here's
what's easy to forget the term has never
been used in a matrix movie before now a
big part of this is the meta textual
nature of the movie much of
resurrections is quite literally about
making a matrix property there are some
curious implications attached to making
a filmmaking term canon
when neo starts to get back into the
flow of things with bugs and her crew
they refer to neo's mojo rising younger
fans or at least those not familiar with
classic rock might not recognize the
reference here rock fans however will
recognize mojo rising as a version of mr
mojo ryzen a nickname used by jim
morrison of the doors jim morrison whose
lyrics were often trippy and
consciousness pushing also went by mr
mojo ryzen an anagram for his name this
can most notably be heard in the song la
woman where he repeats it frequently the
doors also took their name from the
doors of perception a book noted author
aldous huxley wrote about his mescaline
trips it shouldn't be a huge jump to see
how a story about heightened reality and
changing perspective might want to name
drop morrison
free
your mind
later in the movie niobe tells neo my
friends let me make up my own choices
while mulling over the mission to save
trinity whether it contradicts or
reinforces her beliefs from reloaded and
revolutions is like many things in the
matrix movies a matter of perspective
for most of resurrections niobe is stuck
in her ways she refuses to confront the
machines she's not particularly
interested in liberating more humans and
she's perfectly content just running
defense in her own city where this gets
complicated is how it reflects on her
actions and revolutions in revolutions
niobe gives neo command of the logo so
he can visit machine city it's a choice
that she makes of her own free will the
oracle's message to naobi was simply
that she would have to choose whether or
not to help neo naobi's line in
resurrections pairs well with another
observation she makes that she never
believed in the one that might be true
but she may be misremembering the other
half of the sentiment that her younger
counterpart delivered
you've never believed in the one
i still don't then why are you doing
this
i believe in him
unfortunately by the time we see her
again in resurrections it seems that
niobe no longer believes in neo either
after neo reunites with sati she finally
explains how neo and trinity were
revived part of it is a personal
connection her father created the
resurrection pods that brought neo and
trinity back from the dead it's a neat
little bit of continuity and part of it
is easy to miss if you forgot her
father's full title what what was it
again
i am the power plant systems manager for
recycling operations
back in revolutions neo met sati and her
parents at the mobile avenue station
tati's father ramacandra introduces
himself we don't actually see his work
in action but it's quite likely that
recycling involves turning dead humans
into the goo that gets recycled back
into nutrients for the trapped humans as
such it makes perfect narrative sense
that a recycling manager would be in
charge of the titular resurrection as
neo would say
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you